[Music]
here's your money briefing from Monday
July 10th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
the older Americans have a large portion
of their retirement Savings in stocks
wsj reporter Anne turgerson joins us to
explain why financial planners think
that could be a risky move so Anne how
do financial planners typically
recommend that people allocate the
retirement portfolio well you know the
specific allocation recommendation is
going to vary by individual but
typically what you see is for people who
are in retirement approaching retirement
is a recommendation maybe to have about
60 percent in stocks and 40 percent in
bonds that's been the sort of
traditional favorite allocation all
right so that's the recommendation but
what's the reality how much are older
Americans actually investing in stocks
so some data from Vanguard shows that
401k investors who manage their own
money as opposed to relying on you know
some kind of financial advisory service
to manage money for them but these
do-it-yourself investors over age 55 a
large proportion of them nearly really
half held about 70 percent or more of
their portfolio in stocks which is a
pretty aggressive allocation compared to
the 60 40 traditional recommendation now
are these new retirees we're talking
about are baby boomers who might have a
larger portfolio to work with these are
people who are 55 or older so that can
you know be anywhere from Gen X to Baby
Boom to older it's a very large swath of
people some of them have large
portfolios and some of them don't why is
having a higher exposure to stocks later
in life risky so it's risky because if
um you know if you are relying on that
money in other words like retirement is
coming soon or you're already in
retirement and you need to withdraw
money from your portfolio if you have a
large proportion in stocks and the stock
market goes down like we saw in 2008
when it went down pretty dramatically
it's difficult to recover if you're both
taking money out of a portfolio and the
value of the portfolio is declining
swiftly or dramatically so that's why
financial advisors recommend that
retirees have a certain decent
percentage in bonds because bonds tend
to be less volatile the value changes
less dramatically typically so given
that I guess the big question is why
have older Americans become more reliant
on stocks in their retirement portfolios
there's a bunch of reasons you know some
people are still working and you know
maybe they don't have a retirement
dating site you know people who are 55
some of those people maybe are going to
work for another 10 or 15 years or they
don't really know when they're going to
retire but they feel they can afford to
take the risk other people maybe are in
retirement but have other sources of
income that they rely on maybe they have
pensions they have social security they
don't really rely on their 401K Nest Egg
to provide a larger proportion of their
savings they feel they can afford to
take the risk there are other people
I've spoken to who you know are pretty
convinced maybe they're in their mid 60s
but they've had relatives live well into
their 90s and they're pretty convinced
that they need to Target a long-term
Horizon so they're willing to take the
risk because they feel like they need to
invest more aggressively because they
have years in which they think they
might live some other people don't see
alternatives to stocks over the past
decade or so interest rates have been
very low so Returns on bonds have been
low and a lot of baby boomers a lot of
older investors have realized much
better returns from stocks than bonds so
they they see no reason to change that
approach now you spoke with people
who've made this decision to go
relatively heavy on stocks what do they
say about that so people have different
reasons for making that decision I spoke
to one man in New Mexico who got started
saving his 401k on the later side he
tried to invest 60 percent of his
retirement Savings in stocks and 40
percent in bonds but he felt that the
returns weren't adequate to get him
where he needed to go by the time he
hopes to retire which is in a few years
so he decided to shift more of his money
into stocks in order to hopefully raise
the return that he realizes on the
portfolio basically to boost his return
and boost his savings you know you
mentioned that some retirees see no
alternative to stocks you'd think that
people in this age group have seen their
share of ups and downs in the market
over the decades sometimes very sudden
ups and downs and they might want to
protect themselves well people in this
age group have seen ups and downs in the
market but they've also seen the market
recover and they've experienced that
themselves but for a lot of people
they've seen the market move around
quite a bit and they've also seen
themselves be rewarded for holding
stocks for not bailing out of stocks
because you know during 2008 the market
dropped really significantly fairly
quickly and some people bailed out of
stocks and then they came to regret it
the next year because the market
bottomed out a year later and so those
who had fled stocks and put everything
in cash all of a sudden the market was
just rising and they they missed out on
being able to buy it at these bargain
prices so I think some people had that
experience and they learn the lesson not
to do that that was a counterproductive
move in that situation so they've sort
of internalized that lesson it sounds a
lot like what we've talked about on the
show before which is its younger
Americans that typically invest heavily
in stocks so how do financial planners
say that people say in their 20s and 30s
should approach this Market as they
build a retirement Nest Egg so it's very
interesting what's happened in the 401K
area basically over the past 20 years
there's been a growing adoption of these
automated portfolios they're called
Target date funds and more and more 401K
plans are automatically enrolling new
employees and they're putting them into
these Target date funds which are sort
of professionally managed portfolios of
stocks and bonds and for younger people
most of these Target date funds are
heavily exposed to stocks so a lot of
younger people go into those
professionally managed portfolios they
don't even have to make it decision
about how to invest their money the
professional managers of these funds are
doing it for them and they are heavily
allocated to stocks which is what most
professional financial advisors would
recommend so that's kind of what we're
seeing we're seeing younger investors
doing what the professionals say because
they put their money into these
professionally managed funds and they
kind of set it and forget it the Baby
Boomers were not taught to set it and
forget it they were taught to be active
in managing their own money and they're
continuing to manage their own money and
those who are continuing to manage their
own money a high proportion of them are
investing a lot in stocks that's Wall
Street Journal retirement reporter Anne
terguson and that's your money briefing
I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall Street
Journal
[Music]
foreign